i'm not allowed to cross this road
because this is the town of stansted
canada on the other side of the street
is derby line usa and the border between
the two countries runs right down this
rue
the local residents that can be
inconvenient i lived there all my life
so 63 years today you cannot cross over
the line and visit your neighbors like
years ago if you want to cross you have
to report that custom you know i used to
cross every day now i'd probably cross
once every blah blah once a week because
i come down to the post office over here
to go through the border basically they
ask you a passport they go inside i
guess they look at if you have a record
or not they look at your registration of
your car about a couple minutes you're
going through i'm a dual citizen so i'm
american and canadian so
it's easier
this is a place where the idea of a
border as a solid easy to understand
line gets a little bit fuzzy the road
doesn't run at exactly the same angle as
the border not precisely the official
line is that this is canada and that's
the usa but both countries maps show the
road as being entirely in the u.s just
here and entirely in canada up there the
houses are definitely in separate
countries but the road it's not quite as
clear and in practice if i was driving
i'd be okay even on that side of the
road i am considered to be still in
canada as long as i don't stop and walk
up to an american house it's fair to say
there's a little bit of leniency here if
you're just nudging the border by a few
centimeters or if you're on that side a
couple of inches but while i was setting
up my camera here the police turned up
lights flashing to move along those
bikers you saw earlier who were admiring
the view from the other side of the road
it all seemed in good spirits but they
had crossed the border well the library
is part on a canadian site by an
american side but you stay on canadian
side you stay on the sidewalk and you go
through the front door and it's
permitted on canosa street there's a
sidewalk on the canadian side so back
years ago it was tolerated that people
on the american side could cross over
and walk on the sidewalk so you know
basically it's a little dangerous to
walk on the side of the road and now
today well it's not tolerated no more i
think the road hasn't changed much
but they're more enforced when you cross
they ask you more questions than they
used to
you know years ago before you went
through the border and you knew most of
the custom officer and then was they
used to
wave to you you know in 1783 this
section of the canada u.s border was set
at the 45th parallel a line of latitude
slightly inaccurate measurements were
accepted by both countries
so it was locked in but as for this
specific road there are local stories
about drunk surveyors and pranks but
no one really knows
you